I don't think the ego this idea of
Whitney Cummings or this idea of Pete
which is really just an amalgamation of
what your past your physiology your
psychology your the way your brain works
look at your face right
now I really do terrified I no I am like
a big fan of your brain and I'm excited
what you're going to say I hope you like
it this is the first time I've ever
listen to someone well and I'm just like
you're like me
withing listening
I'm genuinely just no you're on camera
listening it's never happened I think
it's important the ego can't be
satisfied right the reason you feel
happy when you get something isn't the
thing it's because in that moment your
ego finally got what it wanted so
there's the cessation of desire you no
longer are resisting reality which is
something you can do all the time but
when you stop resisting so they say this
the great way the Dow isn't difficult
for for those who have no preferences
but anybody can do this you don't have
to be a woo woo hippie you can just say
am I aware and then look check say am I
aware and you find it but it's not an
object it's not a place there's no shape
or color to it it's just it's this thing
and the more not as a thought experiment
that you identify as that
awareness uh the more you rest in your
nature which is spacious Blissful peace
and that is it's not just a
belief that you are awareness it's not
just fun if you believe you're awareness
you can be in my group and we can get
together and talk about and sing songs
to awareness and tell people we
celebrate awareness holidays and when I
die you can give me an awareness eulogy
it's not even about that it's about
right now when I remember that I
am that which is aware of my
experience the clouds lift and I
remember myself and myself is made of
Peace God loves you water makes you wet
you'd like to play this little I was
going to say it's going to ruin the clip
for the religious folks but you want to
play this little game of earning it oh
God loves you when you're good you mean
like your boss at Cheesecake Factory
have a God that's better than the boss
at Cheesecake Factory who loves you when
you're good and hates you when you're
bad kick rocks but like that's what
church did to get you to pay them right
yeah for sure it it that was when the
business of religion came in I and I get
it and there was certain social order
and different motivations I'm not
controls people I'm not it's like what
we do with Santa and kids I'm just
trying to understand that not totally
vilify it but yeah you you create a need
your soul is dirty and it's going to go
to hell but you create urgency right
you're going to die and then you provide
a solution believe in Jesus come with us
that's marketing and that's okay I'm not
even I'm not even doing new rule I'm not
trying to do that I'm just saying like
that's what human beings do the great
the great little joke God and the devil
are walking God uh picks up a stone and
he goes oh it's truth and the devil says
let me organize that for you it's what
we do y we ruin it but the to I I feel
like he didn't maybe you didn't hear me
I'm not sure the whole point is to
accept that you are accepted that's the
whole thing dad's not mad and it starts
with you not being mad at you forgiving
you want to be forgiven forgive you want
to be loved love
you want to be free make others free
it's in the course of Miracles a Jailer
is not free with his prisoner because
you have to watch them right guess love
that guess what you're in jail too
you're just on the other side of the
bars let it all go but guess what you
already did it's just you we drag the
past into this pristine look at how
fresh look at how fresh this moment is
look at how wide open it is um the level
of clarity you've achieved the amount of
work you've done done I can't when
people say like you've done a lot of
work whatever I'm just trying to get to
the question of what if you're like
what's wrong with you no I'm not can you
say that again a different way um uh one
more time come again no is just the
plant medicine the all the work you've
done yourself is there a level of
Consciousness you don't recommend
getting
to well yeah no Pete doesn't recommend
any of it okay because it's the it's the
end of Pete yes like I'm just so look
because I've never done MDMA I I've
there's a buo and the Frog and the and I
see people that are I'm like do I I
remember I don't know this was maybe
like five years ago this is going to
sound self-aggrandizing or like bragging
um I went into do some love addiction
work and then I was you know hardcore in
my out I'm doing EMDR and I'm all this
stuff and my therapist did say something
to me and she was like um just be
careful how much work you do just so you
know there's going to be less and less
people you can date it gets lonier and
loner I actually really agree with that
I she's going to say you're going to
lose a lot of friends when you get
healthy the sick get angry and so it's
just that's a good one you really have
to prepare for how lonely this might get
I love Jay-Z they they he says my friend
say you've changed I'm like you think I
did all that work to stay the same same
and I'm like yeah that's great you know
so so I just am curious like is there a
level of Consciousness that you don't
wish on your worst enemy no well look
the reason I said Pete doesn't like any
of it is because Pete doesn't get to
come the reason why psychedelics sound
like a bad idea to Whitney is because it
is a bad idea for
Whitney it's a great idea for your aw
has to go away yes she I've smoked 5 Meo
uh DMT that's the toad Pete didn't
go you think Pete got to sit at the
right hand of God
hey what do lever do this thing off yeah